uau
lá
ae
é fácil mudar para o chelsea
o tó tó
o papa
o
ae
kkk kkk kkk kkk kkk kkk kkk kkk
vou trabalhar pra cá
ó
hua hua hua hua
o que eu acho
i ai ó
ae
ok
muito obrigado o meu nome é rui paixão
eu tenho 20 anos e foi maquiada
vocês devem tentar a melhor possível
não é muito fácil com 14 ou 15 anos
disseram os médicos
não dá não é muito fácil mas eu consegui
convencê los com muita persistência e ia
e fui estudar teatro três anos os
cadeados e acaba o curso e sempre uma
coisa dentro de mim já vão partilhar
convosco isso vou tomar uma opção de
vida
era afinal já não quer ser ator e
palhaço como é que eu vou dizer aos meus
pais
o ator ainda vá que não vá agora foi
assim o seu agente sentindo e eu disse o
pai mãe e eu quero ser palhaço eles meu
pai então não existe um espetáculo de
palhaço
eu penso pois essa é a escolha do virado
eu quero ser palhaço rua tomás mais
guerreira como não saiu do papel
acho que está a apoiar seu algoz ué por
dia da primeira mas novamente como eu já
disse sou super consistente e vai
começar até o fim eu quero ser palhaço
de rua e 12 ágio de 8 c ajuda dos meus
pais 40 anos que em gaza ou a em 2010
mais 20 e pronto
voltando um carinha tratava eurostat
atribui o meu o meu curso três anos
é uma coisa que me chateia muito mas
muito profundamente que é o ano o
paradoxo do sucesso que está
completamente instalado na nossa
sociedade
tinha que é o que o sucesso é mentiroso
porque o que é sucesso a gnr é nós
fazermos coisas pra agradar um outro
isso é o sucesso não só tem sucesso
quando a lei que diz que nós temos
sucesso está completamente errado
não nós temos sucesso quando fazemos
alguma coisa que o fim do dia mais
simples é que eu deitar na cama e hoje
fiz isto eu estive na rua c palhaço que
o meu sim aí então isso pra mim é o
sucesso do dae é uma coisa que de fato
agradar o outro e foi isso que vou
encontrar o sentido de ser palhaço texto
pergunta muitas vezes eram por que essa
opção se espalhasse isso é ser palhaço
lá
quem é ser palhaço e perguntando também
muitas vezes tu tu és tu achas que foi
assim e isso é o que eu disse não eu não
se pagar se eu tivesse de ser palhaço eu
nunca seria palhaço
o fato de eu ser palhaço só veio porque
eu sentia que não será alguma coisa não
estava bem comigo então eu não considero
um palhaço não considera o ator não
conseguir valores nem nada disso
eu sou um ser humano ea forma que eu
escolhi para me sentir mais humano mais
vivo pois eu conheço e pra mim ser
palhaço não é a caracterização é o
cabelo não é uma maquiagem não é um
livro mário e ciel melhor outra passada
para mim ser palhaço é só um estado de
espírito é só estar resistência amos
freqüência nos encontramos com água
pergunto terminado grau o estado pagar
só isso mesmo é quando nós perdemos
aquela ideia de eu voltar a sentar e
tentar assim desta forma se calhar há
outras possibilidades então você palhaça
isso encontrar minha filha ou outras
possibilidades abrir o horizonte
o jogo é um jogo julgamos aqui todos
juntos foi tudo improvisado e foi
maravilhoso porque o que eu comentei com
o rosto de uma forma diferente
eu não sei dizer que vamos jogar agora
eu tenho encontrado um copo de vinho
quer sair e eu quero passar não lhes era
vulgar é palavra banalização encontramos
outra opção
comunicamos olha nos olhos e igual
acontecer qualquer coisa
isso pra mim é mágico então seu palhaço
por isso mesmo para encontrar pessoas
com um estado primitivo vem antes do
estado social
sua vez não será de hoje está primitivo
chega a ser mais social sustentou
era o que eu tinha para partilhar
convosco o meu nome foi paixão 20 anos e
se um sonho
quando acabei o curso fundar uma
companhia de teatro que se chama câmara
silva
é com a chuva é que o a companhia são
duas pessoas sou eu que trabalho estando
do do clown no teatro físico e outro
abaixo da lei e jogaram os raios que é o
vagabundo também pobre como eu entrei
com os pais é e e é músico
juntos formamos a companhia ainda não se
marcam as chuvas criamos no imaginarius
com o espetáculo de semana lula vai
entretanto mandamos para a espanha fomos
participar num festival em sevilha
chamado ficada que é um sinal assim
mesmo tempo tem um conceito
contemporâneo
quando vemos um prêmio de artistas
emergentes e vamos falar novamente está
com eles vamos passar um mês inteiro de
agosto é no enduro fim de festa do hotel
maior quilate da europa é um dos e para
além disso também fizemos uma
participação não é fraco em honduras
onde apresentava usar aumenta o nosso
projeto em todo o esquema ano culminou a
cerca de três anos com uma participação
que fazer nenhuma vegas uma audição
prosseguiu o sonho do qual saiu
o que dizia um pronuncio ao circo
contemporâneo e com os meus pais eu tô
mais na ala na schola e possui ok mas
muito obrigado a declarar o carlos diz
brandão dizer isso mas eu vou dizer é
momento
durante este tempo todo nós pensávamos
muito na o que o juro mensal a gente
vamos pensar açores no final nosso
espetáculo tal isso que sempre vamos
chegar ao vivo vamos saber o que vamos
dizer e eu então descobri uma coisa que
eu acho muito dizer que estava por dia
com você eo no final de todos os
espetáculos que fazem é tão simples
quanto isto pessoas comam e bebam e e
alegres e viver evitam se viver sozinho